you work together you're very close uh
uh on camera and you're close
off camera what annoys you about each
other just be candid here
oh perfect very little
like i'm true though very little but i
see her nine months out of the year
every year every day every hour and
nothing really annoys the only
two too small like
no no well maybe when she does that but
it's like she is a theater person
she lives as you know now she's very you
know but she's great like you're
extremely talented well thank you
however
i'm not like a theater
she hates like when you say theater do
you mean right uh like musical theater
oh she likes musical theater she likes
music what do you not like about musical
theater
singing i don't hate everything i'm down
like i'm down with a play like people
talking or
you're like yeah and then they sing and
i'm like ah you're watching a play
and people are saying they're lying to
you like people talking yeah yeah
well because like i said right i am
watching the stage of the
actors i'm with you and then you sing
and i'm just done i have to tell you and
i'm being completely honest here
i uh my daughter really likes musicals i
take her to musicals my
wife likes to see music i'm a good guy
but i still at my age cannot
the minute they'd be like i know i sure
have some problems
sometimes i do break into song in real
life the time but so
you know sometimes people are feeling
something and then it comes down and it
doesn't
no no no no no don't do that all right
andy you and andy go to the fed huh and
jordan and i will not no no no i
i'm not a theater i just feel
embarrassed for everyone on stage
just up there being all fake and stuff
yeah
i'm sorry it's no i i'm not offended no
it really bugs me about you
this is awful oh you were just tearing
into each other
you'll understand in a second yeah she
this is i think i know what you're going
to say
but it bothers me about you too that you
like these things i know we'll just be
mutual she is
very close-minded about cartoons i
really don't like
not real people talking okay wait a
minute cartoons are the greatest thing
ever
invented yeah and there's not they're
they're so amazing cartoons i grew up on
cartoons i like like the ones that are
not like the actual drawing of like a
bunny rabbit or something but like it's
like
almost like an animation technology out
of your mind all right so you don't like
cartoons but you like it when someone is
having an emotional problem on stage
you start singing a song about it and
everyone else on stage acts like that's
normal
yes a hundred percent and actually joins
in with the words even though they
couldn't possibly know the words
that's the part that also bothers me i
always wanted there to be a musical
where one person
is in the musical and no one else is
someone else is like
i've got a lot of problems and people
are just like what's wrong with him
put a wallet on his tongue music coming
from yeah that's a great idea
when we do that becomes awesome